[Applause]
this prehistoric bird looks like it
wants to murder you in your sleep
that's probably why it's gays is
affectionately nicknamed the death stare
known as a shoe bill this bizarre bird
found meme fame because of its bone
chilling stare
even joe rogan gave the shoe bill a
social media shout out
the craziest animal of all time but this
bird has other captivating attributes
how big do they get
why do they make such jarring machine
gun sounds
and if a shoe bill gives you the death
stare should you be scared
[Music]
long before the shoe bill found itself
on social media it appeared in ancient
egyptian artwork because it's so common
in the niles watershed areas now these
creatures primarily call the wetlands of
southern uganda and sudan their homes
and because shoe bills don't migrate
they've inhabited these regions for eons
scientists often refer to shoe bills as
living dinosaurs
they evolved from carnivorous dinosaurs
called theropods the same group as the
colossal tyrannosaurus rex
over time shoe bills traded their sharp
teeth and snouts for their large
distinctive beaks
these oddly shaped beaks are the bird's
most striking feature
and remind us of a dutch clog shoe
it measures up to 30 centimeters long
and 12.7 centimeters wide
their bills are large and they're so
strong that an adult shoe bill can
decapitate a baby crocodile oh that is
wet
shoe bills are considered ambush
predators they stand completely still in
the water sometimes for hours waiting
for prey to approach
when a snack finally swims by like a
tasty lungfish their favorite meal by
the way
they plunge bill first into the water
cleaving their victim in two
another striking feature is the shoe
bill's intimidating size
on an expedition to africa in 1840
german explorers were told by an
indigenous guide about an unusual bird
as big as a camel but with a bill like a
pelicans
they were the first europeans to hear of
the shoe bill
they get a gold star
while the shoe bill is shorter than a
camel it's still a big bird
they grow up to one and a half meters
tall with a wingspan of up to 2.4 meters
but only weigh around 6.8 kilograms
about as much as a turkey
in addition to being able to cut their
prey in half the shoe bills engage in
bill clattering which they use as a
greeting and during nesting
this is what creates the startling
machine gun-like sounds they're known
for
shoe bills are also known for their
strange ways of cooling down
ghouler fluttering vibrates the throat
muscles to dissipate heat
a much more unseemly cool down technique
is urohidrosis
or pooping on their legs to regulate
body temperature as one does
you'd think standing in water all day
would be enough to cool them but to each
their own
i'm not judging i kind of am
on a less disgusting note you hopeless
romantics out there might be happy to
know that these birds like swans and
emperor penguins are monogamous
and although you might be scared stiff
if a shoe bill gives you its famous
death stare you needn't worry
humans are predators rather than prey to
the shoe bill a vulnerable species that
is becoming rare
the shoe bill's dwindling population is
mainly due to poaching livestock farming
and oil drilling
these big birds are also targets of the
exotic pet trade
some private collectors reportedly pay
over 10
us dollars to add a live shoe bill to
their menagerie
all right i want names and addresses
one last oddity about shoe bills is that
they invert their pouches beneath their
beaks over their necks and chests when
they yawn
it's called glottis exposure and while
this is a strange trait their pelican
relatives do it too
check out our episode on pelicans to
learn all about it
making machine gun noises and scaring
people with their death stares is what
shoe bills do
and that's what makes them crazy
creatures
you